the son of a lighthouse keeper in the
atlantean Queen Arthur curry was a child
of both the land and ocean his quiet
life was shattered when the obsession of
a treasure hunter named Black Manta led
to the death of Arthur's father leaving
the surface behind Arthur has taken his
place as king of Atlantis protecting
both worlds yet feeling at home in
neither the Lord of Atlantis is a melee
bruiser who excels at solo skirmishes
and poking during teamfights
his passive is rising tide after using a
skill Aquaman gains rising tide for a
short time his next basic attack will
consume rising tide dealing power damage
and healing Aquaman rising tide scales
with power damage and its heal skills
with attack damage Trident of the King
throws Aquaman's trident revealing his
target by marking them with telepathy it
deals power damage based on how far the
Trident has travel stagger swipes his
opponent's feet dealing power damage and
knocking them down
Aquaman rushes through his opponents
with undertow dealing attack damage to
all targets hit if at least one target
is hit
Aquaman may use undertow a second time
within a short window Aquaman's ultimate
mites of Atlantis is locked until he
deals damage with the skill
based on the skill he uses might of
Atlantis unlocks as a follow-up skill
landing Trident of the King unlocks
search allowing a long distance - to any
target marked by telepathy and deals
power damage on arrival stagger unlocks
wrap which deals flat power damage plus
additional damage equal to a percentage
of the targets missing health
lastly undertow unlocks capsize allowing
an additional undertow - that stops at
the first champion seals attack damage
and flips the enemy champion behind
Aquaman try to maximize rising tide by
landing a basic attack between each
skill providing added damage and healing
Trident of the King is a great harass
but has a high will cost so use it with
care in the early game one level in
stagger is very helpful when playing a
solo Lane against melee champions
undertow has good area damage making it
good for clearing drill waves and a
crucial investment on ko City and Gotham
divided learning which might have
Atlantis follow-up to use and when is
all part of mastering Aquaman surge is a
powerful initiator especially against
enemy marksman and supports wrath is a
powerful finishing move so prioritize
low health enemies capsized can help you
escape
or throw an enemy out of position
setting up a tidy kill while rising
tides bonus damage scales with power
damage its healing skills with attack
damage keep this in mind when building
Aquaman artifacts with power damage like
star Heart and cosmic staff afford
Aquaman high burst damage and a more
lethal poke with trident of the King his
low cooldowns make it easy to burn
through will
so consider artifacts with extra will or
will regeneration for extra health and a
little crowd control pick up Atlanta and
Royal Seal built with attack damage
rising tide gives you sustained damage
and health recovery attack damage also
increases under toes ability to clear
drone waves
try huntresses crossbow for cooldown
reduction anatomic accent Kota blade for
more attack damage and penetration for
some extra durability pickup metallus
heart or fragment of Mogo Aquaman
super strength gives you a short move
speed boost after throwing an object
this stolen power shines in scenarios
when you're looking to surprise from the
jungle or escape when outmatched rule
the land in the seven seas as Aquaman
Lord of Atlantis